phones here in the room um please just
turn the microphones off please raise
your hand and make yourself known to
me if possible uh i'll i'll try and
catch you okay thomas over to you thank
you
okay great yes so just briefly to end
here so i got this so in r it is
possible interact to create these
interactive plots so that you can see
you know this is the
um it's a little little flaky because
it's it's in x quartz but it it's
possible to do this as an interactive
plot
okay um
so now
we can talk about instrumental variables
um and i have to apologize in advance uh
because
i'm not gonna get through all of the
slides that i've got here um but i'll
show you
enough hopefully to get you interested
and then
um
at least one of my collaborators um
is currently in berkeley so if you have
more questions you can ask him about the
about the parts that i'm probably going
to skip
and
yeah so um
another point i want to make here about
potential outcomes is the fact that um
these the potential outcome framework
not necessarily the things i'm showing
but the potential outcome framework as a
way of thinking about causal problems is
it's very extensively used um you know
there are certain popular books that you
could read that may you know give you
the impression that in statistics nobody
has been
or applied data analysis nobody has been
thinking about things causely and that's
really not not the case it's just that
often
those models have been formulated with
potential outcomes and so part of the
purpose of these
lectures is to sort of uh
provide a bridge between the graphical
way of doing things which has a lot of
strengths and the potential outcome
framework which also has a lot of
strength so basically two different
languages
um and you know they have their
strengths and weaknesses but they
complement one another
okay this is what i'm going to talk
about i'm going to very briefly uh
review
some points relating to what i just
showed you
i'm going to talk about the instrumental
variable model and motivate that by
non-compliance
and i want we'll think about that in
terms of combining observational studies
which will build on what we just did
previously
um and that will lead to bounce on the
average causal effect and tests of the
iv instrumental variable model
and then what i won't have time to go
all the way through is um
describing approaches such as
statistical inference i probably will
i have time to tell you a little bit
about uh basic approaches i'll
um
i'll i'll sort of tell you a naive way
to do bayesian inference and then i'll
tell you a a way that is um
that avoids the problems that my
approach uh has and i yeah i may just be
able to touch on frequent disapproaches
but probably
lunchtime will be calling
so i i should also give you some caveats
here especially if you're
coming from econometrics or um
i i should say
um the approach i'm describing here this
is like a question that got asked at
last session the approach i'm describing
will make minimal assumptions and it'll
be valid you know even if the instrument
is is weak if you've heard of what that
is
if you don't know what it is don't worry
um but it will only consider
binary treatment and outcome um although
there are some extensions and it will
also obtain bounds not point
identification um so i just want to let
you know sort of full disclosure here
there's a huge literature on
instrumental variables and here i'm just
focusing on categorical uh treatment
and outcome so you know this is partly
because it's
i think it's easy to unders in some ways
easy to understand and it links to the
things that are described
um in the first session and it will also
in some ways set things up for what
we're going to talk about this afternoon
but um there is you know um there's a
lot more
very very large amount of instrumental
variable approaches out there
okay so summary so far we had a
randomized study
okay and i
expressed it to you in terms of these uh
independences
and um if you were sort of paying
attention um the last two days you'll
have seen sort of implicitly uh
um where we have
a cause and an outcome and we have no
confounding this is how it's represented
in the graphical framework the sort of
convention that if i'm not if i'm not
explicitly including a hidden variable
then it's presuppose that one is not
there
whereas an observational study where we
have confounding would correspond to
the graph on the right where you know
one of these independences doesn't hold
and we saw that um
in the randomized study
the
the
margins of the potential outcomes were
identified the joint was a 1d set we saw
that in the
randomized racial study
the margins were not identified the
joint was a 3d set
over here the ac was identified here we
had bounds of length one
okay
on to instrumental variables so just to
sort of
give you uh uh
provide a provocative example to think
about and provide some motivation
you know if you've taken an intro
statistics course
um often it's presented that well you
know from randomized experiments we can
draw causal conclusions and then
depending on which course you took
you're either told that it was
impossible from observational studies or
maybe you were told we have to be
careful or you know it depends exactly
but um
but you might have wondered to yourself
well wait a second you know
is this really a hard and sharp
dichotomy between randomized experiment
and the non-spatial study you could sort
of think about well
you know could i imagine could there be
something that was somewhere between
a randomized experiment and a
and a an observation society is this
maybe
you know is there something which which
you know for example what happens when i
do a randomized experiment things don't
go quite as we hoped so here's an
example there's a lot of text on this
page you don't need to read all of it um
but it's it's sort of there
to provide the
gritty realism
um
uh so this is going back to a um
this is an announcement of us of a
the result of a drug trial is in the
lancet
um and
um really the thing
so
the conclusion was that uh this drug
oral cancer activity has failed to bring
symptomatic
uh cytomegalovirus infections in a
double-blind placebo-controlled trial
and it says you know this seems to
contradict those with a similar trial
indicating that it did reduce this
disease
um
that study was conducted you know uh in
parallel and earlier to the the uh the
study that's being reported here then
there are details about exactly how the
study was conducted 662 volunteers were
in the treatment group and 332 to
placebo
and then this is the sort of the summary
organisation did not prevent symptomatic
cnb disease to a clinically or
statistically significant degree
the niaid concluded in its announcement
also also the drug caused significantly
more adverse effects than the placebo
okay so this is the
this is a summary as we said it's being
published to the lancet so you know this
may say more about scientific journalism
than
what i'm about to show you but this is
what the lancer didn't say
the data analysis here used an intention
to treat method
what does that mean intention to treat
method means that it examines the
difference between those acetate
treatment versus those asked to take
placebo they were double blind but
regardless of what they actually took
and that becomes very relevant
in this uh study because you know there
were
um
this was a point where there were
treatments being worked out you know
where there weren't uh
um
successful aids treatments available so
there were a lot of ethical issues about
how people being in the control arm and
so after the cpcra study began the one
that i showed you the report so the
results for different study involving
725 subjects
showed a 49 decrease in the number of
clinical cnb infections in the group
receiving this this drug
consequently for ethical reasons the
cpcra allowed the subjects in its
placebo arm to take organ cycloview
intention to treat analysis ignored this
fact and the lancet did not mention this
problem
okay
so hence the study
that's being reported compares the
effect of asking people to take the drug
versus the placebo
but then giving everyone the drug anyway
so it's not very surprising under those
circumstances that
it doesn't uh the intention to treat
analysis here doesn't demonstrate an
effect of the drug
because if if you sort of we look at the
intention to treat versus intention to
give placebo but then ultimately
we don't go all the way through on our
intention and we give everyone the drug
then it's not very surprising we're not
going to see a difference between the
treatment and control on
so
of course you know uh the film version
of things is never quite as uh it is
always a little bit uh
um simpler than what really happened
you know in fact the people in the
control arm only got two months of gain
cycling whereas they've got nine months
in the treatment arm but still hopefully
the key thing i want you to take away
from here is we can do a randomized
study
and things can go badly wrong okay so we
can have a randomized study where
um
people do not comply with their
treatment so it's not that i'm going to
give you any magical way of
of sort of fixing this problem but
it's to motivate
um thinking about non-compliance so
we're now going to think about a setting
where
patients are assigned to treatment or
control that's randomized
but then
we then observe whether or not the
patient takes
more than a certain amount of the drug
and we then have the patient's health
outcome so for example you know we might
be
giving a patient a set of pills
and that's you know double blind and
randomized but then maybe the patient
isn't taking all the pills that we're
asking them to take
and for certain settings people get
especially worried about this
that they um you know they they build
uh
pill bottles that sort of record when
they're
when the pills are being taken out so
that you can you can track you know the
extent to which people are doing what
they're being asked to do
so here is a stylized data set i'll say
in a moment why it's stylized but this
is a color thyroin trial this is one
that pearl considers
so we've now got you know these three
binary variables
so it is the arm that people are
assigned to x is whether whether or not
they took more than a certain amount of
the drug and then why is the final
outcome
and then these this is the data that's
observed um and these two zeros here
are in red because
this was a experimental drug so there
was no way that people in the control
arm could get access could take the drug
at all so anyone that was in the control
arm was not going to have a one here
they're all going to have uh zeros so
that so these entries are automatically
zero
but then in the treatment term
the stroke you know was for uh uh it was
to reduce the rest roll and
it also had some side effects i think it
uh gave people gas
i think it may have been that they even
added that so that people got certain
amount of gas even in the control arm
but but anyway the uh um
the the the the uh
uh the
basic point is that not everybody that
was asked to take the tree ended up
taking it so i have to give a caveat
here which is that
compliance was actually measured as a
continuous
variable um it was dichotomized by pearl
and not necessarily arguing that's
justified but it's useful to just have a
simple data set to think about there are
other examples i can give you where
compliance definitely is binary and we
may get to one of those
okay so the key thing here is we did the
experiment we randomly assigned people
to be in the treatment group versus the
control group but not everybody did what
they were asked to do but we have a
measurement of whether or not they did
what they were asked to do
and uh we what we would like to do is to
recover
we'd like to recover what we would have
seen had we done experiment with perfect
compliance okay so had we been
you know somehow able to um
i don't know um
make sure that uh that everyone was
taking their
that that the drug um
you know who was in the treatment done
so here's an idea you could say to
yourself okay well that's a pity people
didn't do what we asked them to do
but maybe we could think about this as
just two observational studies so here's
our first observational study
and here's our second old spatial study
so we could think about this
randomization is essentially just
randomly assigning
people to participate one of two
observational studies
and then you know what what differs
between the two studies is is um
how likely people are to take the drug
in those two observation studies so in
in the you know in the in this in this
obsessive study
everybody's certain to take control
because you know this was the control
arm so nobody in this observational
study
is actually getting treatment at all
that's we've got these zeros
but then here
here in the um
in the treatment arm
you know some people
are taking treatment some people are
taking control
okay so we just went through if you were
here for the first lecture this morning
then you know we just did a very careful
analysis
that allowed us to work out what were
the potential what were the possible
distributions relating
um treatment and outcomes from an
observational study so now we've got two
observational studies
so we could look at them look at both of
them
okay so this is what we would get from
the z equals zero arm yeah we actually
in
here things become degenerate because
right uh it was an observational study
but it was a very boring observational
study where
everybody got control right it was
absolutely study where nobody
chose to take treatment
so we end up just so it's just like we
just end up with this this
two-dimensional plane
the other the treatment arm right some
people are choosing to treat treatment
some people are choosing to take control
so we end up with this
polytope
rhombic mcdoderin
but
people are randomly assigned to
participating in these two different
observational studies so therefore
um uh uh
we it's you know these these are both
it's reasonable to think that these
proportions help hurt always recover
never cover the same
in the two arms
also because we're supposing here that
which observational study people are put
into
doesn't um change the way that the drug
affects them okay so in particular we're
supposing for example that
the people up here
uh the people up here who who are
assigned to um
[Music]
who who are assigned to disarm where
this study where they can only take
control they only get the control they
have no way to take the active treatment
the way they
respond it's the same
as the way that uh um that the people
here
uh respond to um control so in
particular we're sort of ruling out the
possibility that the people that down
here get some kind of frison
of
of of rebellion because they you know
they were asked to take the treatment
they don't take the treatment so we're
supposing you know you could imagine a
world where the people down here have
some sort of a massive adrenaline rush
from defying authority that the people
up here don't have we're supposing
that's not the case and i'll formalize
that shortly so we're supposing that how
the people respond to control or
treatment if they were to receive it is
the same in these two studies but we've
got these two observational studies so
people are selecting for themselves in
these two studies whether or not they
take treatment or not
so under those circumstances
we could then
we could then take the intersection of
these two okay so we could then
we could in the same way that we did the
intersection of the two planes in the
where we had the two ions from the
uh from the randomized study here now
we're combining the two observational
studies we're combining the z equals one
information and the z equals zero
information when we take the
intersection of those two
we get this nice little
uh shape down here which
it looks as if it might be a rectangle
but it's actually a little hexagon
[Music]
so why is that interesting
that's interesting because now if we do
this last step
of flipping this
thing over and uh so projecting out
always recovering just looking at it
from underneath
okay so here i've uh this so these two
this plot and this plot this is just you
know taking this one you take each of
these and looking at from looking at
them from underneath
um
sorry
this one this this taking these two
plots and looking at them from
underneath we then get these two
pictures
and
now we've got more interesting story we
can see here that when we
combine the information from both of
these observational studies
we end up with
bounds on our average causal effect
which now bound
the average causal effect away from zero
okay so we can see here the smallest
value of the average causal effect
uh corresponds to
uh to the points here which gives us an
average causal effect of 0.39
the largest corresponds to this line
which is
average causal effect of 0.78 so here
we've now
taken the information from this
imperfect experiment where people didn't
do what they asked what were expected to
do but we've still been able to salvage
things and we see that now there was uh
a a non-zero average causal effect the
average cost effect was positive
okay
so
so now you see that was why we bothered
to go through and work out those
polytopes this morning because now when
we take those two and intersect them now
we get some non-trivial information out
okay so there is a there is some
sometimes when people see this they sort
of think wait a second hold on you must
have pulled a fast one on me because
the data from each arm each arm was an
observational study and uh we this
morning we had this kind of good news
bad news story where we saw that
when we get the information from an
observational study
um the bounds always contain zero
and always have width one
so the data from each observational
study is compatible with an average
causal effect of zero
so how come
when we combine the information from
these two studies we have ruled out the
possibility of the average causal effect
being zero
[Music]
it seems it may initially strike you as
a little bit of cognitive dissonance
there but if we go back and look you can
see what's actually going on here
which is
yes the data from each arm
is compatible with average causal effect
of zero so average causal effect to zero
corresponds to the sort of the plane
going through here where helped and hurt
or equal
and so we can see yep there's a little
bit of this green plane that is compared
with helped in her equal to zero and
there's a little bit of this
uh purple polytope that's uh compatible
with average causal effect is zero
but what we see is that
uh
that those two
uh the the scenarios
that are compared with the average
causal effect being zero under each
uh each of these sets are very different
so under the z equals zero arm we have
average causal effect to zero but we're
way down here in the bottom
where we have
very few people of type voice recover
and many people have tight never recover
whereas when we are
when we are
in the look at the data from the
treatment arm we have to have many more
people of type always recovering in
order to have
uh the average causal effect the voices
have helped and hurt um uh being equal
okay so so essentially another way to
say this which may be perhaps easier to
think about
is that if we
if we um if we project
and then take the intersection
then so if we project down to these two
dimensional shapes and then take the
intersection then yes we will end up
with uh um
the intersections of projections will be
larger than the projection of the
intersections so if we first intersect
and then project we end up with a
smaller set
any questions so far
yeah so one
one difficulty i'm having
and maybe this is the computer science
trying to think in the worst
case but
i guess
you don't have zero inside here but
that's only for one particular example
like i think i'm having trouble making
sense of the geometry without seeing
some uh like the inequalities written
out but i guess that like
it could be the case that
you know when you give everyone the drug
nobody decides to take it in which case
i i would presume we're we're
in a bad
scenario there where we somehow can't
rule out certain things or that's like
there's no randomness there i suppose
but could you highlight a little bit
more about
i know i guess
the confusion that i'm having yeah so
certainly it is certainly the case that
um
i mean for example if it is the case
that
the two observational studies turn out
to be exactly the same so uh so you know
so somehow
um i mean yeah we'll talk about this
experiment for example
a very common experiment like this is an
encouragement design where people are
encouraged to
to to take the treatment so for example
educational interventions where there's
some random subset of people who are
encouraged to go along get optional
tutoring but maybe there's another
people
this is a real study where people
randomly assigned
to have their doctor encourage them to
get a flu vaccine versus another group
of people who didn't have that
um
[Music]
so yeah so if it's the case that that
encouragement has no effect at all
on whether or not people uh avail
themselves of the treatment or avail
themselves the extra study then of
course we're then back to the scenario
where we've just got one observational
study and we are going to contain zero
so there's no
is that certainly the case this is not
guaranteed to be informative and there
will be many circumstances where these
bounds will still contain zero it's just
what's what's nice here is that at least
sometimes we are able to get informative
bounds
there are also other things that can go
wrong and i'm going to talk about them
uh um in just a second
okay
you know is it uh is it possible that
these two polytopes actually don't
intersect yes that's that's what can go
wrong yes i will uh we'll talk about
that in just a second yes you're
stealing my thunder but i always think
that's a good sign when people
can see further ahead yes
so
the bands that we get here what i've
shown you these are bounds that were
recently derived by bulky and pearl um
and they obtained them
from a different perspective
where they
um
they had they had types for both um
both the
compliance behavior and
the response
and they use computational algebra um
and so the thing which is nice about
this approach is it sort of allows us to
see where those bounds are coming from
and we'll also see it also generalizes
to situations where there are more
z-arms but x and y are still binary
okay so just to formalize this a little
bit more
here's our our um
here's the the model that we've been
talking about thinking about it this is
as a graph
um z is what's uh randomly assigned
here's x and here's y we're allowing um
confounding
and we have sort of potential outcomes
which is
uh
for x and y so the potential outcomes
for x are you know whether or not you
avail whether a particular person avails
themselves of treatment when they're
assigned to
treatment or control
and then why is as it was before it's
how the person's responding to x
again i'm using that same shorthand
and uh randomization assumption here
we're just supposing z is is independent
of uh because it's randomized it's
independent of our potential outcomes
and we have what's called an exclusion
assumption which is we're supposing that
the only way that z influences y
is through x okay so we're
uh so sort of here
our potential outcomes with essentially
we could index the potential outcomes
for y by both x and z
but we're supposing that the potential
outcome for y only depends
on x
so that that was what i was saying we're
assuming that
that the way that the person responds to
placebo
is not different uh
depending on you know
it's not different because they get this
sort of adrenaline rash from from
disobeying authority when they're in the
treatment so we're supposing that's not
the case we're supposing the only way
that z influences y
is through x
[Music]
so these are the assumptions that we put
into our model
so
these are the types that we saw before
relating x to y but in addition we now
have four other types relating z to x so
we have the always takers never takers
compliers and defiers okay so complier
is someone who you know
does as they're told that the fire is a
person who does exactly the opposite
sometimes called um that there are a lot
of the fire three-year-olds out there um
in my experience and then um
you know always takers is the person
who's always going to take and and never
take a you know so in in the study that
we were talking about before
um if you're in the control arm you had
to get
zero so therefore in that study we're
actually we only had never takers and
compliers there we're no always takers
or desires
okay so we can come up with a two-way
table similar to the ones that we looked
at this morning
um
and you know so for example just to talk
our way through this
if we look at this entry here so this is
the person assigned to control
sure enough they got control and they
had a bad outcome so that person is one
of two things they're either never take
it and never recover so
or never taker and helped okay
um
uh
sorry
um or they could be comply or never
recover or they could be comply and
helped
so the basic point is they had x equals
zero and y equals zero so that means
that we know they're of type never
recover or helped
and they had z equals zero and x equals
zero so we know they're of type never
taker or comply
um
if if in addition the same person so the
people that are in this cell here
are people that have
under control
x equals zero and y equals zero and
under treatment they have x equals zero
and y equals zero so it doesn't matter
what arm we assign them to
they
don't take treatment
and their um
and their outcome is is zero in both
cases so
then we know that their type never take
it because they have x equals zero
regardless of whether they're assigned
to z equals zero z equals one
but they could be
um they could be no of type never
recover or help
and so the way i sort of describe this
is
the people that have typed never take
her and never recover are just sad right
it was somebody who there was just no
way that we could have helped them it
didn't matter whether they took the drug
or not
they were going to have a a bad outcome
but the the sort of the people who are
of type never take her and help it's
tragic right because these are people
who
um who it doesn't matter whether we ask
them to take the drug or not they won't
take the drug
but
the tragedy is that if somehow we had
managed to
you know convince them to take the drug
then they would have had a good outcome
okay
um
this this entry here this cell here is
empty and the reason for that is anyone
think why there's a reason that
let me talk through what's going on here
so if someone were if there were people
in this
cell they would have
they would be people that would have
um x equals zero regardless of whether
they were assigned to control or
treatment
but they would have
y equals zero if they were if if they
were
assigned to control but y equals 1 if
they're assigned to treatment
so this would mean now
that somehow z was having an effect on
their final outcome
even though
they have the same value of x in both
arms okay and so that would violate our
assumption
that z only affects y through x because
somebody in here would be somebody who
when they you know doesn't matter which
arm we put them in they have x equals
zero doesn't matter if we ask them to
take treatment or not so that they're of
type never taker
but somehow
uh yes somehow when they're when they're
in the treatment arms they're again
their defiance of authority just in this
extra
power and they have a good
outcome whereas uh up here
um they don't get that adrenaline and
they have uh they have a bad outcome
when they when they just
are asked to take placebo and duplicate
take placebo
okay so that's why these entries are why
there's no one in here because under our
assumptions
we've ruled out
uh these possibilities and that's going
to turn out to be very interesting in
just a moment
okay so
just to kind of say a
couple of words about previous results
so robbins and mansky derive natural
bounds on the average causal effect in
this particular setting
um and these bounds are not sharp in
general if there are defiers
they follow from weaker assumptions they
follow from just
these two micellar independences
um bulky and pearl derived the closed
form expression of the ace bounds
that are tight by a computational
algebra
and those expressions are maximum
minimum over eight different expressions
but ultimately they've that's the same
thing as the
the calculation that i'm showing you by
intersecting those two polytubes
and they would
rederive the bounds
without explicitly using potential
outcomes again using computational
algebra
so an advantage of the approach i've
shown you here is that
supposing i had more z arms
i still have x and y binary but i have
more z arms then i can extend the
analysis i just take the intersection of
more polytopes
so it generalizes to arbitrarily
many um said arms
uh and
yeah so essentially this is just saying
that i think maybe this was even a
question that was asked in the audience
so you know here these are the same
bounds that i showed you
this morning for the observation study
but here we're just
taking we're taking the minima and
maxima
over all of the different uh z
observational studies
so yeah this real this is really saying
nothing other than
construct a polytope for every one of
those of yours said arms
every one of your observation studies
and then take their intersections
and then if you then finally ask about
the average causal effect then you know
then you can work out the bounds on the
average causal effect and they turn out
to take this form
and this exploits the fact i'm not going
to go into a lot of details but this
exploits the fact that um
that
uh the the margins here um are variation
independent i can come back to that if
people are interested at the end okay
on to a point that was raised earlier
which is couldn't this happen
could it be the case that the two that
the two
polytopes don't intersect
yes it could that's entirely possible
um
and
it turns out that the situations when
the politics don't intersect
corresponds exactly to the circumstance
when
uh
corresponds to the situation where
these bounds on the margin that we have
the upper bound
could be less than the lower bound
[Music]
and i'll give you a bit of intuition for
that in just a moment but so in the
simple case where we've got going back
to z being binary
we end up with these four inequalities
okay so these four inequalities define
the observed model
in the uh in the binary case and so the
thing i want to so to say here
is that um
you know in the talk yesterday
um and i guess also
on tuesday there was a lot of focus on
causal models giving rise to conditional
independence restrictions
but um here the interesting thing is
here we have some inequalities and those
inequalities actually turn out to be
useful and interesting so i mean if if
we go back
tying this back to what we talked about
before
on on monday and tuesday if i
show you this graph
here
right then
h is unobserved
you should if you sort of took in d
separation you'll see there are no d
separation relations that hold you right
because the only place where we could
potentially have these separations
between z and y
the z and y are obviously d connected
given the empty set and they're also d
connected conditional on x by this
pathway
so we have no d separations
but we still do have these um
inequality restrictions
let me give you a little bit of
intuition about these
so let's take and take this example this
is saying that
under this model
this probability
y equals zero and x equals zero given z
equals zero
plus this probability
y equals one and x equals zero given z
equals one
better be
less than or equal to
um
uh less than or equal to one
so let's have a look here and see
why that uh why that has to be
so this is saying that when i add up
this number plus this number
those two better not add up to
um better not add up to more than
um one
and you can see why that has to be the
case supposing i tell you that this this
you know this number here is 80 and this
number here is 70
then you'll say okay so this number is
80 so that means these four types
are 80 percent of population
and then these four types are 70 percent
of population
so that means we've got 150 percent of
the population is corresponds to these
eight types
so essentially the issue is that because
the set of types that we have here and
the set of types we have here have no
intersection
therefore um they cannot add up to more
than 100 so the reason we've got four
inequalities is because we've got these
four
empty cells
why wouldn't matching with defensive
cores or something like that be a more
natural approach to solving these types
of problems
well i mean i guess the issue is um
so the the
i guess coming back to this
you know that depends on whether or not
you believe that you really have no
enough so the preventive score approach
would be if i've got lots of data if
i've got lots and lots of data maybe
i've got enough data that condition on
that data
um
uh
you know i i don't need the instrument i
can just view this as an observation
study and i've got enough data that uh
conditional on those covariates is
something we'll talk about
this
this afternoon but like the back door
formula
that sort of x is as if assigned at
random conditional on those covariates
yes uh if you if you really believe that
then um
that would
then that would be another way to
analyze this uh and indeed
you know
certainly there's a lot of interest in
triangulating things so um for example
combining information from an
observational analysis and maybe some
analysis where we have an instrument
i think the real power here comes from
the fact that
uh you know in settings like um
you know encouragement designs
you know if we do have an instrument and
by so this is a thing i i want to stress
which is that
i think the reason why graphical models
are not used more frequently for causal
analysis is because
every graphical model starts off by
requiring you to know something about
the structure typically
in order for the analysis to go through
yes there are learning algorithms but
it's it's you know not that common that
learning algorithm gives you just one
structure back
and so
so in typical cases the the researchers
being required to make a guess as to
what the right causal structure is
and if and everything that follows from
there depends on that guess being right
here
yes okay there is some information that
we're using here we're having to
we're having to suppose that our
instrument affects x
and doesn't directly affect y except
through x
but but those things can be we can set
up designs that make that like okay so
if we do a double blind randomized
experiment
then
that gives us some reason to think that
zed cannot be affecting y except through
x
and the fact we've randomized z means
that we know that there aren't other
edges into z here
so so essentially turning this around
if i was wanting to sort of uh you know
i i i think these methods i think
adjusting for background variables using
the backdoor formula
those methods complement this kind of
analysis but i will say what this
analysis has going for it is that if
this bounce the average causal effect
away from zero
then the assumptions
the assumptions that the analysis rests
on are assumptions that you could
make hold by design
whereas you know any propensity score
analysis is going to depend on
choosing the right covariates specifying
the model
you know
you're up against the potentially up
against the curse of dimensionality
there you know it's a lot of a lot of um
you will be relying on many more
assumptions typically
okay
yes
could you go back to your two-way table
[Music]
yep
so in order to
give a bound on ace you uh computed
these two polytopes intersected them and
now you got the the bounds
so looking at this table
i think you can do it more directly
right so i see here
a polytope
as a as a pre-image of a map from
15 dimensional simplex to eight
different seven dimensional simplex
as you have the the variables you know p
n t comma and r etcetera are 16 of them
um and then you have the marginals there
are eight of them
so that's going to give you a polar top
and then you can give you can get a a
linear map that's going to project to
the probability of h e and ar and
whatnot so you're going to get another
pole top that way so can you not do that
to compute the bounds on ace instead of
yes yes you certainly could do that and
that's how pearl did it
originally he did it
exactly in the way that was done here if
you look in his book that's how he went
ahead and did it but but there is a
downside to that which is that as
as the number of levels of z increases
and the number of uh types you'll have
for the x is growing quickly
and so people have not uh so so the
advantage of doing the
presented in the way that i've done
is that essentially it divides up the
analysis
um so yeah so if if i think basically
people hadn't done it
you know if you try to do this where z
takes three levels or four levels or k
levels
then computationally this um at least in
my understanding i think in terms of the
uh
the the analysis uh um the dimension of
the analysis explodes whereas you know
by doing it this way that i presented to
you
um
you we can visualize everything that's
that that's going ahead and we can do
arbitrarily many levels of zed
uh without having to
um
yeah so that that's basically w with uh
purely by thinking about one arm at a
time right let me just i mean follow up
questions that do you know how they
compare in terms of bounds you get at
least in in situations you can compute
they're they're identical yeah i don't
segment yeah oh
the bands are saying that's what i said
here i said
i said
uh i said i don't know i said earlier
that pearl got the i said the bounds
that he got he got by doing principal
striker so but but pearl only gave them
for zed taking two levels
one more question
thank you
thomas could you go back to the diagon
instrumental variables
yep
i just wanted to make a comment actually
not not so much a question about the uh
discussion on propensity score methods
which is that um
uh it's related to what thomas was
saying which is that
with instrumental variables right you
don't need to observe h
you don't it can be an unobserved
any propensity score methods you need to
observe you need to have measurements on
all of the relevant confounders for the
causal effect you want to identify so
it's a pretty big advantage of
instrumental variables i think just that
you don't need to have observed which is
basically what thomas was saying
yeah i agree with that
[Music]
but i mean it does have to be said that
you know we're not
what i'm presenting is giving bounds
okay
so now now hopefully you see where all
these inequalities come from
um
and
so these were also introduced by pearl
and generalized by bonnet
um and then further generalize on uh by
that cadania and marithia i'll talk
about that in a moment and these provide
a falsification test of the binary iv
model so basically if you violate these
inequalities
then we know
that the uh that the iv model does not
hold
um but
um and at least in this simple case
uh um it corresponds if you violate
these inequalities a way of thinking
about this is that you're actually able
to
work out
that um
if we continue to maintain the
assumption that said was randomized so
you know we believe that said was
randomized then essentially
if we're violating one of these
inequalities what would what we're able
to do is we're able to work out that z
does have an effect direct effect on why
um
uh holding x fixed which which you can
sort of see from the fact that what what
are we doing when we violate one of
these inequalities we'll work out that
one of these entries here is greater
than zero so we're working out that
there must be some people who even
though they get have would have the same
level of x regardless of which level
upset they got then their y would change
[Music]
okay so these are the inequalities
um
so that's what i'm saying here it can be
interpreted as bounding away this guy
away from zero
the average direct effect i've said on y
holding x fixed at x
this this set is not so easy to uh to
visualize
um but we can we can at least think of
it sort of three-dimensional shadow
three-dimensional projection
so if we take the left-hand sides of
these inequalities
we could define new variables
corresponding to each one of the
left-hand sides
and then obviously because we've got two
we've got all of the possible values for
y and x when z is zero and all possible
values when set is one if we add up all
of these guys it's going to sum up to
two
so therefore these these quantities here
have to live in the
two the simplex of
points that add up to two
and then these inequalities here then
cut out this little octahedron inside
the
this so this is this is letting us see
the projection of
the
the so the the
the iv model
is a set of distributions over y and x
given z equals zero and y and x given z
equals one
so formally that lives in a six
dimensional space
it's not you know it's not super easy to
visualize what that is but here i'm
showing you what the projection is when
we project from that six dimensional
space down to three dimensional space
which lets us see
that um
which lets us also see
that uh
that we have um
uh
that each one of these inequalities is
um
[Music]
uh that at most one of these
inequalities could be uh
um
violated so uh ismail's asking a
question saying uh
um yeah so israel is asking is it not
the case that we could get the pearl
inequalities under weaker assumptions
and that is indeed uh the case um yeah
so i'm i'm not claiming the conditions
i'm giving here are the weakest possible
conditions to derive the i've er that
pearls inequalities um but yeah uh so
this the claim
i wasn't saying that the independence
the potential outcome independences were
were
necessary to get these
bounds on the acs merely that they are
sufficient and indeed
you can derive these inequalities even
without um
without having potential outcomes over x
uh if you're willing to assume that
there's a latent for example
okay so these are some uh some related
works um
and
so this is sort of moving more in
statistical direction so up to this
point i just treated it as if we have
huge sample sizes and we know what these
distributions are so we're really just
thinking about identification but of
course in reality we don't have huge
sample sizes
um
and we need to think about the fact that
uh that there's there's a statistical
noise in there
in our accounts
so lawrence and ramsar biometric paper
provide an approach for testing these
restrictions
the restrictions that we've got here so
it's not as simple as just plugging in
the
uh plugging in the empirical
distribution here because even if the
model's true we might just by chance
violate one of these uh inequalities so
lawrence around to high priority a um
approach via likelihood procedure
combined with the bootstrap
um
i have a paper with
um
limbo wang and jamie robbins
that test this allows you to test these
in the presence of uh in the model where
we have baseline covariate so that's
like a model where
um we have
where we have the usual iv model but in
addition
there might be some
baseline uh covariates that everything
is conditioned on that this model holds
on so there's like a v that's a parent
of
of uh um
of uh zx and y
uh and
but then there's been more work since
then um and so
uh cadania and mauricio uh showed
got additional constraints so bonnet got
constraints that uh arose when there
were three arms
canadian mauricio gave all of the
constraints and they also provided a
testing procedure statistical testing
procedure using the sample splitting
procedure uh china should crop it out
okay so i've got a few minutes as i
predicted i was going to run out of time
i'm going to tell you very quickly tell
you about
two approaches to bayesian inference one
that's naive and one that's not naive
and then i will give you
basically it's probably about 10 seconds
to say that there are other frequentist
approaches um
okay so up to this point we just ignored
sampling variability we i've just taken
the data and essentially we just um
uh you know if if we had had time we
could have generated these polytopes
using the empirical frequencies
and intersected them
in fact that's what i did i yeah i
generated those politics using empirical
frequencies
but of course we don't really know we
don't get to see this distribution
exactly so one way to take care of
something variability is the way that
pearl explicitly advocated in his
uh in his uh 2000 book this is in some
sense the sort of the one part that is
statistical where he's taking into
account sampling variability he says
let's just put a dirichlet prior on this
on on our
types this 16 different types
um and then we could use mcmc to sample
from the posterior distribution given
our observed data so let's see what
happens with this in the case of the
lipid data
so here these are the mysore prior
distribution so recall that in that
lipid example the cholestyramine example
there are only two compliance types
comply and never take it because if
you're in the control arm you weren't
going to get the treatment so the only
two compliance types would comply and
never taker we've got our four response
types always recover help hurt never
recover so we've got eight types that we
have to worry about in this setting
uh and so this is this is the micelle
prior distribution you get here i just
put down uniform
on this on the simplex and then these
are the posterior distributions okay so
these are my subprime posterior
distributions this is actually a
distribution that's living in a in a
seven dimensional space but i'm showing
you the marginals
okay so here this is now showing you
we're looking at the average causal
effect from the lipid data
and you know it lives on minus one to
one the green curve here is the prior
distribution before we see any data the
red curve here is the posterior and
these dotted lines here are the upper
and lower bounds that we will get out
from just plugging in the empirical
distribution into pearls bounds
okay so far so good but then
suppose that we perturbed this prior a
tiny bit so uh i'll zoom this a little
bit
okay so here i'm perturbing it so
instead of it being
directly one one one one one one one
it's now we'll changed it to be
dirichlet111 1.2 1 0.8 so i'm making a
very little change to this dirichlet
uh prior
so you can see here on the prior
right this is before we see any data i
think you're slightly more likely to be
never taker and help slightly less
likely to be never taken over recover
but then when we see our data and
remember the data that we had here the
smallest count was about 12 or 13.
there's still a big difference we've got
a big difference in the posterior okay
so this was the posterior before this is
the posterior after
i make this tiny perturb to the prior so
i make a tiny change to the prior
and if you've seen bayesian inference
before maybe you haven't but if you've
seen bayesian influence before in
typical
problems that are
properly identified a tiny change to a
prior like this would not
precipitate such a big change to
posterior when you've got reasonable
sample sizes which you know here we
don't have huge sample sizes but we
don't have you know
the smallest count was 12 or 13.
[Music]
and this is what happens to the average
causal effect okay so here you can see
the dotted
curves show the prior and posterior
after we make the tiny perturbation to
the prior
okay so you can see here
maybe you don't get too excited about
this but i mean you can see the
posterior has chains right the posterior
previously looked like this
now i make this little change to the
prior you can see we've got this dotted
thing and if you look at the median here
here i'm showing you the median it's
moved and the interesting thing is that
the median of the posterior has moved
more than the median of the prior
so when i first presented this to
raising colleagues these amazing
colleagues not working causal infants
they said oh well you know this is to do
with your priors not diffuse enough you
should have a more diffused prior
because here look the support of the
posterior you know there's conflict
between the prior and the posterior the
data and the prior having it sort of not
happy with one another you should have a
more diffused prior and this problem
will go away
so
we could try unit information prior so
here instead of it being one one one one
one i put 1 8 1 8 1 8 1 8. so this is a
more diffuse prior and i'm also doing a
perturbation
and now you can see what happens we get
kind of the doctor's use
posterior okay so essentially
uh the the 1 8 1 8 1 8 1 8 prior gives
us this sort of peak
bimodal distribution
and then when i make this
little perturbation which is actually
smaller than the one i made before so i
just move 1 16 from here to here
we get this you know huge shift
we've got a huge shift
okay so what is this meaning it means
that essentially you know this is the
kind of bayesian model your parents
warned you about okay so what's
happening here is
that you know if i'm a bayesian and i
have this prior and you know i'm making
a decision i have this prior i compute
my posterior i make a decision great
there's no problem but usually bayesians
when they do analysis they want to show
them to other people
who might have slightly different priors
and what this shows us is that taking
this naive approach of just putting a
prior over all of these types
and then proceeding ahead with the
analysis the results are then very
sensitive to changes in the prior so if
somebody presents you an analysis like
this
the question you should ask yourself is
you know well that's great i'm happy for
you that you know what your posterior is
but why are you
why are you telling me about it because
if my prize slightly different
then surely
um
then you know my posterior might be very
different to yours
that's a sign telling me that i've i i'm
over time
okay
so let me just say very briefly we can
get we can come up with an alternative
way to deal with this uh problem
by basically just formulating the model
via these inequalities so what we can do
is we can formulate our model directly
as a model on the observed distribution
okay because the observed distribution
is identified under the model
and so essentially
we really parametrize so instead of
franchising in terms of those 16 types
we re-parametrize in terms of the
observed distribution which is
identified and the parameter here i'm
calling alif is this is a parameter
that's completely
non-identifiable so essentially
uh that um
if if we start off with independent
priors between these two things
and however much data we have our
uh our beliefs about this are not going
to be changed by the data that we see so
essentially a way of saying this is
whatever you believe about this you
better be comfortable with it because it
doesn't matter how much data you see
you're going to continue to have the
same beliefs and so in particular
just to be concrete about what this is
this is something like the ratio of
these two types
so it doesn't matter how much data
doesn't matter how much data i see
i'm not going to be able to learn about
the
as unless i do a different experiment
where i somehow force people to get x
equals zero or x equals one as long as
i'm just doing an experiment like this
i'm never going to be able to learn
anything about the ratio of these two
joint types never take or never recover
never take her and help
because
they always show up together in the
likelihood
so
yes so this is to say
essentially um
to do a bit proper base analysis uh
where you're not
um you can re-parameterize then this
part of the these parameters are
identified these parameters are
completely not identified and so you can
then you know
you can then either compute posterior
distributions on the bounds which is
what i'm showing you here i'm showing
you posteriors on the bounds and i'm
perturbing the prior and you can see
there's no change at all
or if you want to know about the average
causal effect
then
you can
make the posterior on the average causal
effect a function of a sensitivity
parameter so this is a quantity that you
can't ever learn about it's about the
proportion of never takers who would
recover if we somehow force them to get
treatment
and so we can do a bayesian sensitivity
analysis
and unfortunately that's it i'm going to
have to
stop there but there's lots of lots of
interesting related work and there are
great people at
the science institute who
at the moment who can tell you about it
so i will stop there
[Music]
thank you there was one question going
back to the instrumental variable uh
discussion that you had earlier
that i missed that time uh from andrea
where she says i believe you mentioned
earlier that weak instruments were
another problem that aren't weak
instruments complicating the inference
about the vowel
no
no they're not
not going to all that's going to happen
is that the bounds will be uninformative
i mean the bounds will contain zero but
the inference here
um
both methods so i don't didn't have time
to get into it but basically uh we can
also do
um there's a method
um that uh
the method that came up uh
um developed with uh richard that
is based on coming up with uh
a competence region or the bayesian
approach both of those methods the only
issue which is going to arise is that
the um that the bounds will be
uninformative
so so that's yeah it's not going to
um
the inference is going to be fine the
influence will come
in the limit
you
you may make e independent of x it's
like you have two populations where you
basically have two observational studies
i mean you have two replicates of the
population you you take two samples
right and that's why
and the limit basically you don't have
information you
basically get two poly tops that
eventually converge to the same place
yeah you have an intersection is that
right is that trouble yeah i mean yeah
basically yes exactly i mean what's
going to happen is i mean you'll get
your posterior is going to end up
being
where you know
it's quite correct that we're not going
to get informative inferences
i absolutely agree with that but it's
but there's nothing going to go wrong
with the citizens right right
now yeah i have a question
so thank you thank you thomas uh i have
a quick question about the inference
procedure when you are using the
bayesian method yeah
and this is going back to my question
about when you
you impose your assumption on the
potential treatment right because
for example to get the average treatment
effect is not clear to me that you
really need to impose any independence
assumption on the potential treatment
right
and
what you call x x of z yeah in that case
in your bayesian approach you have to
define this prior for the whole
dimension
so if z
has a multiple value
you have to define the posterior of x
over x of z and also y of z right as the
way that you define here
and y of x okay okay so so just to be
clear there are two bayesian approaches
i was presenting one which is the one
that pearl described which i was
critiquing i may not have made that
clear enough i was critiquing that
approach that was approached where we
put a joint distribution over x of z and
y of x
so i was critiquing that approach and
what i'm arguing is instead
not doing that i'm instead arguing for a
different approach where we just put the
posterior distribution directly over the
observable model
okay so so i'm i'm advocating an
approach where we go directly for
inference about the observed
distribution
we learn about the observed distribution
and then i completely agree with you we
could get the bounds without having to
talk about the potential outcomes for x
absolutely agree with you i yeah i
haven't been emphasizing this at this
point here because
i'm trying to get people to sort of
understand facial outcomes and so i was
you know doing it with x potential
outcomes and wide potential outcomes but
you're absolutely right that we could do
the same analysis without that
so when you you get you put this
this posterior on the observed
distribution you are basically getting
like uh you dominate the procedure that
was proposed by pearl before in terms of
like good fit and everything in general
i mean they're answering different
questions okay essentially that the
so
um so
the first thing i'm doing is i'm doing
inference for the observed distribution
right the observed distribution is
constrained by those inequalities and
i'm doing inference for that
distribution that's the first task
and then the second thing then there are
different things we could do one thing
we could do is we could say well we
could we could work out so in general
working out the set of unidentified
parameters in the in the simple case
that we were doing where they were just
never takers and compliers
it's quite easy to describe there's
really only one
prompt extra parameter that one needs
which is this thing i called here that's
the
proportion of never takers who would
recover if they go x equals one
in the general case where you've got
defiers and compliers and always takers
and never takers it's a more complicated
story that you need sort of three
sensitivity parameters and they don't
have quite such a simple interpretation
but in principle the same analysis can
be and i yeah i have a valencia paper
with um jamie and and robin where we
where where we went through and
and did that um
but yeah and then basically there are
two options you could do one option is
you just say
you know i just want i want to be like
the frequencies i just want to compute
posteriors on my bounds
right
the other thing you could do but
is you could say well no but hold on a
second we actually have to make a
decision here come on guys we need to
make a decision and if that's the case
then then i think the thing
you know then then somebody at some
point has to kind of
decide i'm the guy that's deciding these
are my priors
i'm now going to now sort of feed those
priors in
on on on you know this stuff that we
can't learn about i'm going to be very
brave i'm going to put my prize down on
that make a decision use my utility
function and we're going to do something
but the but the one point is at least
in terms of presenting my analysis to
people this is sort of like lemur i
think has a
ed lima has this distinction between
what he calls private analyses and
public analyses instead of so private
analyses are like what i was describing
i'm the beijing i know my prior i'm
going to compute my posterior and i'm
going to make a decision on what we're
going to do
but to other people
i don't see whether they should
necessarily be very interested in in
what that posterior is because if their
pride is a tiny bit different
than their posterior and so partly i was
provoked in in wanting to look at this
because there was a talk that don rubin
gave where he was analyzing the same
model but
in fairness a much more complicated
version where x was continuous where
where compliance was continuous
and he did this analysis and and uh one
of my colleagues said well this is very
nice but you know this model is clearly
not non-parametrically identified
so uh your analysis the fact you're
getting these results out either
they're being driven by your prior or
they're being driven by some parametric
assumptions you're making which one is
it
and i mean it would his response was to
say
well you know basins don't really care
about identifiability
and at that point i sort of felt like oh
really they don't care about
identifiability so this is basically to
make the point that well you know
yes it's true if i'm just computing the
posterior and it's for my personal
consumption
and i'm going to make the decision
and nobody else is looking at it then
yes we don't need to worry about
identifiability but if uh
if anyone if i'm telling anybody else
about my posterior then probably they
want to know
how much of it was informed by the data
and how much of it was this stuff that
the data told us absolutely nothing
about
thank you very much
okay thank you i don't see any more
questions in the room or
so thank you very very much thomas we'll
take a two hour break and then reconvene
thank you